Jamel s'il te plaît viens viens nous
rejoindre
parce que
c'est la surprise Jamel Debbouze a fait
le déplacement pour ce gala caritatif en
soutien au Maroc après le séisme
meurtrier l'humoriste originaire de
Trappes n'a pas fait que rassembler les
artistes du Jamel Comedy Club ce
prétexte était important je rentre du
Maroc et on a conscience des besoins on
connaît bien la communauté marocaine et
pas seulement à trappe et c'est pas il y
avait pas que des Marocains aujourd'hui
heureusement mais on savait que si on
envoyait ce signal il allait avoir un un
écho ça le plein est survolté les 800
places de la Meurisse se sont vendues en
moins d'une soirée pour soutenir la
population marocaine et puis chacun
participe comme il peut et là voilà
montrer qu'on est tous solidaires faut
toujours faire un petit peu pour la
population ben comme vous voyez moi
c'est le drapeau du Maroc parce que je
viens de là-bas donc il faut aider quoi
on savait qu'il y avait vraiment une
appétence pour venir apporter son
soutien et marquer par rassemblement
notre appui au peuple marocain mais
aussi vite aussi fort avec autant de
monde réussi attendez pas et vous l'avez
vu beaucoup de nous disent merci d'avoir
organisé ce temps parce que au-delà de
l'humour et du bon moment passé ensemble
c'est une façon d'être solidaire
collectivement sur scène ils sont quatre
à s'être succédés entre humour et
solidarité mais rien Benoît est né à
Casablanca c'est magnifique de pouvoir
aider et faire rire les gens il y a que
du bon dans Ça c'est trop bien j'ai
adoré jouer devant eux ils sont
tellement chaleureux bienveillants et en
plus on sait tous qu'on est là pour une
raison pour cette raison là pour aider
le Maroc donc du coup il y a vraiment
que de la bienveillance un spectacle
caritatif au profit du Secours populaire
le gala lui a permis de récolter plus de
7000 euros le Secours populaire des
Yvelines c'est vu remettre un chèque de
5000 euros de la commune ça va servir à
acheminer et à distribuer des produits
de première nécessité donc là ils ont
déjà commencé sur place à distribuer du
matériel pour que les personnes puissent
faire la cuisine et des panneaux des
panneaux solaires pour pouvoir permettre
de s'éclairer une collecte de produits
de nécessité est aussi en cours à trappe
vêtements chauds tentes couvertures pour
donner un rendez-vous au centre de
loisirs Petit Gibus